me gary got together yesterday
and the whole conversation was was robin
ever in love with you
and i said yes
and gary said yes oh please and i said
robin hell is wrong robin's into this
whole honesty thing but she won't admit
it yeah gary goes i know exactly
he knew it too gary goes i know both i
know exactly when robin was in love with
you really yeah and i go well let me see
if i pinpoint the same exact thing
all right so you write down what you
think and i'll write down why don't you
all do it now so anyway fred you don't
believe that ever happened do you yeah i
do oh i do believe all right write down
when you think it happened no i'll tell
you when it happened
you started falling in love with me in
washington
toward the end of our stint in
washington and you loved me almost uh
all through nbc
[Laughter]
i said i thought it was the way you
describe it in the book that you you
know howard was great he was amazing i
had to meet this other person no you
cannot tell from robin's book when she
she blocked it all out
you cannot tell from her book when she
fell in love with me i know because i
know when a woman's in love with me oh
you're so crazy in fact you know what
i'll give you a story i'll give you a
story you let me write you a book
give me a story i'll write your secret
oh you're so waggy you know what you
still have to look at love believe me
howard when two artists
connect creatively like that every day
there has to be something going on of
course
i think this is all transference i think
you have been in love with me oh i i
don't deny it
at least i'm professional i don't want
you see the theory is that you want me
no no no
you have wanted me oh of course but i
admit that those beauties come on of
course i'd want you
i want fred
but i don't you know hey is fred in love
with you
that's another show uh yeah
yeah
yeah let me let me think about that in a
sense yes
any sense yeah man are speaking yes yeah
well how come i can't be in a manner of
speaking no you're not you're the way a
woman loves a man because i'm a guy and
you're a girl now you ready to confess
no you have never been in love with me i
love you i love you oh beyond reason you
never want to have sex with me on
anybody in the world but i've never been
in love with you right now take a deep
breath for a second excuse me could you
guys be quiet for a second would you
guys leave the room for a second
leave the room i want to talk to robin
privately to you right now no let the
guys leave
all the guys are gone now you don't have
to keep up your front
you don't have to act tough nobody
listens there's nobody there's no one
listening now look at me can you
honestly say yes
there did not come a point uh-huh where
you look at you you're getting dreamy
did not come a point
where you would look at me and say hmm
maybe i should have sex with howard i
would like to have sex with howard you
were gonna you were gonna go on record
and say
all right because equations you're being
dishonest
i'm being dishonest yes you're being
dishonest i've never wanted to say and
never at nbc never at the end oh that is
such a lie i've never had cbs never
and would you be willing to take a lie
detector test yes you would absolutely
all right it will be done gary all right
everyone back in the room jerry
i want her hooked up fine
we have ed the polygraph guy over there
there he's hooking her up now yeah and
he's going to ask her all the questions
okay is your first name robin yes
ed writing down
something
i dig ed though ed the polygraph guy
he's a cool guy he's good at it yeah
he's good
would you like to have sex with howard
stern no
that sounded like a lie to me
i thought the needle job
noah no
that was a lie i bet you that's a lie
wait till we get the results i guarantee
you she's thought about it have you ever
been in love with howard stern no
that sounds i could hear a voice shake
when she said it she doesn't sound like
herself no did you notice this is
serious robin quivers is quivering
have you ever had sexual thoughts about
gary
no
i believe that that's the truth that's
not a problem i don't believe it i
believe she's telling the truth
is everything single and your book true
yes
is every single thing in your book true
yeah i know you can't laugh at the
questions crazy she's crazy
all right
obviously what question is that
have you ever gone
you read it
have you ever cut your hand over your
butt farted and smelled your hand no
hey ed the polygraph guy all right ed
how you doing man okay ed and i have
never met before you meant it obviously
yes he had to give me the test uh i
assume ed that by the fact that you're
in here you have now come to some
conclusions right true for right now
every all of america is waiting on your
words okay is every single thing in your
book true it's true she was she was true
truthful truthful thank you but ed can i
ask you a question isn't it in her own
delusional world that she might have she
might believe it's true or maybe my
better
memory
another test right that's another test
exactly you got to get into my work
no one knows what's going on but at
least robin believes it to be truthful
good that's good okay yeah right the
farting question
that one he didn't know and you got no
result on that huh right right yeah you
won't you don't trust the result what
result did you get just out of curiosity
well she really uh she really got
you know upset by that question and i
was upset by you and she was like a mess
yeah she got upset by it and and
although it probably isn't accurate what
was the was the answer truthful no she
she's never copped her uh
she never cuffed her butt and farted
into it and smelled her hand
okay now let's get to the good stuff now
all the sexual questions would you like
to have sex with alex stern she said no
and she was truthful about it now when
you say that she was truthful about that
there wasn't that word in a couple of
different ways and i there wasn't the
question have you ever thought about
howard sexually that's the one i'm
interested in
because i believe she was in love with
me perception she likes you but she
doesn't love you she likes me but
doesn't love me
hmm
are you sure i'm telling you let me see
ed i don't know if you know you're gonna
trust the polygraph
16 looks like a lie to me
all right so you're saying that robin
was honest when it came to the fact that
uh she is not in love with me right
she's not alone she's not in love with
me she's never been in love with me
and she's never had sexual thoughts
about me
well i personally think you were in love
with me i don't care what anyone said no
matter what the machine i don't care
what the machine says